I'm about to clear the board as promised
what I'd like you to do is if you have a
look at worth example 10 part a it says
find the value of K how are you going to
do that look at the question you've got
some probability density function it's
equal to KX squared but K is unknown how
can we do this because I'm gonna get you
guys to do this on your own how are you
gonna find K it's a probability density
function right so something equals to
one what equals to 1 for all probability
density functions the integral of that
KX squared but from where like just the
integral it's the integral in a specific
spot right we're shown so from a any
from B and they tell you what a and B
are I think for memory is 2 and 5 to a 5
off you go find out what K is okay find
out what K is and then I'll pick up from
Part B okay this is this is my working I
apologize it's a little small I'm just
trying to fit everything on there okay
just to make sure we we know what we're
doing here right what we can say is
since this is a probability density
function therefore if I integrate it all
over over its entire domain from here to
here right and put in my probability
density function there you add up all
the probabilities you bear to add up to
1 and then basically from there I just
kind of let the calculus take care of it
make K the subject you find dot dot okay
is 1 on 39 okay so far so good
so how do we progress now that we have
this have a look at Part B use
integration to determine the expected
value of a random variable X if it is
distributed according to P of X there's
a lot of words in there the important
ones are expected values so Part B we're
gonna go ahead and we're going to work
out what the expected value is okay now
because working out the expected value
on this is more or less identical to how
you worked out the expected value on the
other ones just for a different function
okay I'm actually just skip that a
little bit so I'm gonna show you what my
working
looks like okay so um don't stress out
too much about this because I hope just
like in worked example eight you could
follow this through can you see what
I've done right I've worked out the
integral of X f of X but now I know what
f of X is instead of saying K I say x
squared on 39 because that's what I just
worked out k to be okay I'm off you go
you integrate you put in your upper and
lower boundaries as necessary and you
get this guy um what I write 203 on 52
okay now this is where the question then
says you've got expected value now go on
to variance but I want you to put your
pens down and look up with me so you can
see where I'm about to go cuz I'm
actually gonna lead you a slightly
different direction to the question okay
here are our two ways of calculating
variance the things we were right at the
start of a lesson okay here's the kind
of the standard form this is the
definition of variance but then I said
to you like I times don't like doing
that because it ends up a mess here's
another way we can do it okay now have a
look at this probability density
function is it a uniform distribution is
it is it uniform no it is not uniform as
your X changes so does the probability
okay so I'm going to tell you right now
I'm gonna ask you to trust me for our 10
minutes I'll show you I'll prove it to
you in 10 minutes but for these 10
minutes trust me if you try this method
out the first one we use with this guy
it will just blow up in your face okay
you'll get the right answer but it's a
nightmare to get there okay so I want us
to try using this other guy over here
now this guy over here have a look we're
gonna work out this integral here you've
got it written down and then we're going
to subtract this this is mu right this
is our mean our expected value we're
gonna subtract the square of this guy
okay but that means we need this piece
this is the piece we need okay so let's
go ahead they actually here miss value
to you but I want us to prove that that
is the value and it's it's actually not
that hard so let's have a go I want to
try and find the integral
from A to B which in this case is two to
five naught of X f of X I'm gonna do x
squared f of X okay so Casey like in
principle this is going to be no more
difficult than what you just did with
expected value with the expected value
is just a single X now it's just x
squared okay so it's not like a
qualitatively different problem there's
just a different power there so just go
ahead and make sure we know how to do
this my f of X in this case we already
said was x squared on 39 yeah x squared
on 39 said okay x squared f of X so what
I'm getting is x squared times x squared
which is X to the 4 right add your
powers there yeah is that okay you can
tell with that so now I'm ready to
integrate so this goes up to five
because I increased the index to five
I'm gonna divide by five thirty nine
times five should be 195 but go ahead
and papi and calculator if you don't
trust me
two two five and now I just need to I
just need to evaluate this it just give
me a number 5 to the power of five 525
625 three that are you gonna knees gonna
have to help me out I don't know what
the answer is it's three thousand or
twenty fives the next one but I've got
to get one more so it's like 20 mm I
don't know what the answer is
can someone tell me I need the number oh
I skipped nice skipped 125 didn't know
yeah
525 125 six so I do end up on three one
two five yes
to the power of 5 is 32 someone popped
this into their calculator and tell me
what that is one zero three one over 65
which is on your piece of paper already
but with one subtle difference as soon
as you get to this point please put your
pens down cuz I need to highlight
something important and so I want to
make sure I've got your attention to do
it
she's making sure we're all there wrong
color okay now we get to this outer a
thousand and thirty one on what again
thousand thirty one on sixty-five okay I
better I better write that down because
we're gonna refer to it a thousand and
thirty one on sixty-five but I want you
to look closely at what the question
says they say that this value is equal
to this question mark you're like
where's that okay I want you to look at
carefully of this and where I said that
we came from have a look at it stared
really hard with me okay remember I told
you this is a lot like calculating
expected value remember that except
instead of an X there's expected value
right I put in an x squared remember
that right right so because I'm doing
this x squared it's really the expected
value of x squared and whatever I put in
here it's the expected value of that guy
okay now the reason this is important
the reason I'm highlighting it's like ah
why so many ways of writing the same
thing so if you ask the question before
what's on the reference sheet and the
answer is this guy okay this guy is on
the reference sheet so even though this
is what you're actually calculating this
will actually be what it's often written
as because as you can see this is more
succinct than that okay I know you're
brain hurts right now so does mine but I
promise with familiarity it'll be just
like differentiation and regular
integration you'll become more
comfortable with it so give yourself
some time okay so now that we have
worked out what oh here it is what this
guy is see that we just worked out that
it's 1031 on 65 now I'm ready to work
out variance so variance equals okay
that guy thousand 31 165 takeaway mu
squared whatever mu happens to be
thankfully we already worked out what he
was it's this guy
squid okay this is just calculator work
someone already worked it out it's like
zero point something I know that because
their small numbers been zero point I'm
not sure what it is anyone get there
give me um give me give me four decimal
places six two one five and some other
stuff and that's it
there's your variance if you um if you
wanted to then work out what standard
deviation was you'd take the square root
of this guy
can someone go ahead and say square root
answer for me because there's just an
avid calculator seven eight eight four
cool I'm do okay now I said to you
before right we've got these two methods
for working out variance we need to
choose carefully it's a bit like when
you were differentiating you're like ah
[ __ ] use the question rule [ __ ] is chain
rule and obviously choosing one way
sometimes a lot more efficient than the
other I asked you to trust me for ten
minutes that this would be the better
way to do it I'm going to show you now
what happens if you try the normal way
on this question okay and I just want
you to know this really hurt to do this
but I did it so that I could prove to
you guys that we're not just saying you
should do this this is the alternative
okay so have a look right where it's
still more if you have a death wish
okay now just just have a look at the
working with me and and you'll see why
why this method leads to this problem
okay see when you've got X minus mu or
squared X minus mu all squared okay
here's my he's my Mew right here so I
put it in I want X take away mu or
squared you can see it over there on the
left hand side okay and then I also have
to multiply by my f of X which in this
case is x squared on 39 okay but when
you go ahead and do that we can't use
reverse chain rule any more like sham
Barbie suggested in the worked example
eight don't worry you're not in trouble
it was because you got something right
okay we use reverse chain rule before so
we didn't have to expand you cannot do
it if you have something
yes and that's why it just explodes into
a disastrous mess okay so this is what
is at stake in terms of like knowing
which one to use if you want again the
shorthand uniform not uniform and that's
kind of the easiest way to tell which
one you should use
okay oh absolutely you should because
they're both equal you better get the
right answer but it's just one way sucks
like the Sun the Sun set on me while I
was doing this question and I had to go
home